the first phase for villain of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe has been
officially revealed thanks to some
leaked set photos how's it going
everybody it's Warren and today we have
an official look at the villain of Black
Widow in the very first villain that we
are discovering a face for in the MCU
this villain is the one and only super
assassin and mercenary taskmaster and
this could reveal some very big things
about the future of the MCU not only
ingest phase four but also phase five
phase six and other phases that are to
come
because taskmaster is associated with so
many different characters not only
heroes but a lot of villains as well
he's been a mentor to some big villains
and he's also taken on some big heroes
as well including the Avengers and
Spider Man I'll break it all down in
this video but first if you would like
to win a Captain America shield an Iron
Man helmet an Infinity Gauntlet or
another Marvel Legends item be sure to
subscribe to my channel so you can enter
my giveaway I'll be picking three
winners at four hundred and fifty
thousand subscribers so as you can see
in these photos the villain for Black
Widow has been revealed and although it
doesn't look completely comic accurate
everybody is saying that this is in fact
taskmaster
so taskmaster from the comics typically
has a skull face and a hood and a cape
and as we can see here in these leaked
photos this taskmaster that is going to
be in Black Widow is wearing a full
helmet with body armor in fact a lot of
people have been joking around online
saying that he kind of looks like a
Power Ranger he also seems to be wearing
some sort of a backpack on his back
which many people believe to be a type
of jet pack now taskmaster is actually a
pretty good choice for a villain to
introduce in Black Widow Black Widows
expertise is in hand-to-hand combat
fighting and weapons now taskmaster is a
genius and he's also an expert in
hand-to-hand combat and weapons as well
but what makes taskmaster so different
and so dangerous is that he has
photographic reflexes now what this
means is that he can look at somebody
fight only one time and then completely
mimic everything that they do this is
what makes taskmaster so dangerous is
that he can mimic you and beat you at
your own game this is a really big
problem for Black Widow because she
relies heavily on hand-to-hand combat
and weapons but the fact that taskmaster
going to be in the Black Widow movie
means that we could be seeing some other
characters into the MCU as a result of
this taskmaster was a mentor for
crossbones and Diamondback but he's also
worked for Norman Osborn who has been
heavily rumored to be introduced at the
end of spider-man far from home so
perhaps they're planning to tie-in
taskmaster with Norman Osborn in the MCU
but taskmaster has also worked for
Agency X the shadow initiative and
shield so there are plenty of stories
that they could incorporate there but
taskmaster has also fought a lot of
different superheroes some really big
superheroes including the Avengers
spider-man Captain America and he's also
fought Deadpool and Moon Knight two
characters that everybody is really
looking forward to see in the MCU so
taskmaster entering the MCU via the
Black Widow movie is actually a really
good way to do it so they can set up
taskmaster to be a big villain based on
what happens in Black Widow but they can
also set up other villains based around
the events of what happened in Black
Widow for future MCU movies and since
it's heavily rumored that Norman Osborn
will be entering the MCU soon it seems
like we might get that sooner than later
so we have our first villain for phase
four of the MCU be sure to comment with
your thoughts on taskmaster being the
villain of Black Widow and one of the
first villains that we'd get for phase
four and also be sure to comment with
your favorite superhero or villain like
the video and subscribe to my channel so
you can enter my giveaway and stay up to
date on everything related to the MCU as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof